[Musique]
métro simplon xviiième arrondissement de
paris cela bichat est un jeune prêtre de
33 ans en soutane et en france depuis
huit ans ici il retrouva concentré de
son pays d'origine la serbie
et à voir
slavica est un des trois seuls prêtre de
la diaspora serbe à paris entre les
baptêmes et les mariages ici slavica
connaît tout le monde pour les nouvelles
fraîches du pays il va chez selon la
presse
[Musique]
son ami beaux gosses av yvan la presse
de tous les pays d'ex-yougoslavie beaux
gosses avaient serbe du monténégro
slavica et serbes de bosnie aujourd'hui
dans la boutique le magazine qui attire
son attention
cp jat1 mensuel d'information serbe ses
pales de l'actualité c'est notre patrie
h et mes bien aimés
ils savaient à chrome os adressé aux
fidèles comme les encourager pour faire
le bien pendant les bombardements
pendant les clans expulsion des serbes
de croatie etc
il était là pour eux pour calmer les
esprits
le patriarche c'est le modèle de slavica
loin des balkans le prêtre incarne la
religion auprès de ses frères et ça
commence juste en face à l'église saint
sava qui rythme la vie des serbes de
paris depuis plus de 60 ans
tous les dimanches slavica accueille les
fidèles orthodoxes originaire de serbie
et des autres pays des balkans
jésus leur dit je vous riez s'attendre
tombé du ciel comme l'est
cette icône du christ a vu défiler deux
grandes vagues d'immigration en france
les premiers serbe débarque dès 1945
pour y trouver du travail puis à partir
du début des années 90 pour fuir la
guerre en ex-yougoslavie
aujourd'hui ils sont environ 20000 à
fréquenter les bancs de l'église saint
sava
les gens ils se sont retournés vers
l'église désire et qu'il fallait une
guerre pour que les gens ils retournent
vers la religion entre ce que ça a été
un jeu le délai c'est un peu des
générations ici on se pressent à
l'entrée pour acheter des cierges qui
seront brûlés en souvenir de la famille
restée au pays
les plus pratiquants crack même pour ces
icônes à l'effigié des saints chaque
famille serbe a le sien un patron qui
protège et assure la santé
et pour le petit vidéo
le culte des saints patrons c'est une
tradition orthodoxe serbe on les fait
une fois par an et cette cérémonie c'est
là cela va
[Musique]
autour de cette table les familles sont
venues célébrer leur saint protecteur
l'archange michel
à l'origine de la cela va il y a les
cérémonies païennes de l'antiquité une
pratique religieuse transmise de
génération en génération et malgré tous
les empêcheurs de célébrer en rond là
cela va est devenu le ciment de la
société serbe
pour nous les gens le plus important
année
parce que c'est noël c'est quelque chose
qu'on a tous partagé le même genre
tandis que si vous voyez l'identité de
la slave à quelque chose qu'on va qu'on
va partager mais qu'il y ait encore plus
à notre famille
[Musique]
goussainville en banlieue parisienne
slavisa est invité à l'as là bas de ses
amis igor et natacha
[Musique]
comme le veut la tradition ils ont
dressé la table autour de l'icône de
saint michel
au menu le collage a pas sacré symbole
de l'unité familiale
[Musique]
nous sommes là aujourd'hui pour partager
partager cet amour de notre
icône il nous a accueillis aujourd'hui à
maison devient comme une église en fait
c'est pour ça que vous avez peut-être
remarqué quand vous êtes entré que la
porte était ouverte en fait on a même
carrément est pas le droit de refuser
l'entrée à quelqu'un dans les pays de
l'ex yougoslavie
la tradition est forte natacha partage
plus qu'un repas les souvenirs des siens
et de son enfance au pays c'est celle de
corée c
est pour moi j'ai perdu mon besoin est
ici c'est
j'ai ma maison là avec mon mari et sa
race et
comme j'ai quelque chose de chez moi ici
qui se pose
là cela va ça sert aussi à ça un vrai
moment de convivialité entre amis mais
ce soir ce la vie chère ne s'éternisera
pas il est attendu ailleurs
il est 21h comme toutes les semaines
slavica bien transpiré sur un parquet de
basket l'autre religion des serbes
même si on perd je me fâche
mais il faut aval à
la colère divine
depuis plus de 40 ans les serbes sont
des dieux du panier à grands coups de
titres mondiaux il redore le blason
écorné de leur pays
on a pu prouver qu'on on était des ponts
sportif qu'on pouvait gagner et qu'on
reparle et de la serbie
d'une autre façon que
de l'exercice s'est passé chez nous dans
l'équipe de cela bichat il ya des serbes
des français et même un croate comme
l'orthodoxie le culte du basket ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières de la serbie
[Applaudissements]